I'm here with Ian white at Wales
comic-con have you been enjoying the day
it's been a lovely day and of course we
know you from many characters in Game of
Thrones don't we which one do you enjoy
playing the most was this Gregor white
Walker and giant in season 3 as well
well everyone loves a bad guy and go go
go go Gregor Clegane is without doubt
one of the worst characters ever
committed the literature let alone film
or television you know playing a villain
you can always let go completely forget
about reality and just and just go with
it
but Gregor Clegane is when these
characters were which requires you know
real emotional as performance because
this is a man who lacks any kind of
humanity or emotion on any conceivable
level but yeah he's a it's a difficult
character to play but he is he's
enjoyable
have you found stepping into the boots
because you took him on in season 2
didn't you yeah it's always difficult to
step into another actors shoes you know
but it was just one of those things they
asked me to do it and I said yeah sure
he's been talked about by Robb Stark in
season 3 recently as being a mad dog
without a strategic thought in his head
so what do you do to psych yourself up
to play a guy here is that craving he's
quite got a bit of rage on him hasn't he
Craig Gregor yeah well you know he lacks
emotion on any conceivable level a
emotion any humanity on any conceivable
level you know he's a rapist he's a
killer he's a child murderer um
you know you don't I don't have any any
sort of relics perience in these things
glad to hear so it requires a great deal
of inventiveness and in season two in
these inner things that I did as his
character it basically came down to
sucking all the emotion out of the
performance no David Nutter who is a
director at the time he came out to me
and you say love way doing do less of it
yeah so it just came down to just doing
absolutely nothing and trying to play it
an absolutely deadpan as possible do you
think how long do you think a character
though because he's emotionless as you
say but I kind of feel like it might be
like a turmoil inside him and obviously
has a lot of rage and since he kills a
lot of people does he likes killing how
long do you think someone like that can
survive in a show like Game of Thrones
so do you think he's got what it takes
to survive oh my god he's making enemies
left right and center all the time you
know something a matter of time before
someone does it Ben it could be any
number of ways we go with Thrones I've
seen some very inventive deaths how
would you like to go if you had to get
the job how would I like to go if you
surrounded by dancing girls doesn't like
a Monty Python scene is it a truce
which is a matter of your death that
mana sounds a bit like something I
Tyrion would pick actually if you're a
foodie do you think I think deep down
he's got a sense of humor I think
somebody asked me once if you you know
put yourself actually in Westeros and
you know imagine if you if your
character ascended to the the Iron
Throne of Westeros what would be your
first decree as king and I said my first
thing I would do is melt down the bloody
Iron Throne and replace it with a sofa
and I get a man of range balls it
comfort that's a little bit did you see
in the show do you see happening or
would you like to see happen a kind of
showdown between your brother Sandor and
Gregor um yeah they'll be kind of cool
but um you know we're beholden to the
writers and
who are of course beholden to the writer
so if that doesn't even read all the
books and if it doesn't happen then it
won't happen in this year in the series
you do as you say you're into a lot of
fights don't you you know a man who
backs away but is the only one in the
show you think you know yeah I'd like to
take them on actually who needs to die
you mean who needs to die um general
Slynt he needs to go he's horrible yes
everyone goes everyone goes eventually
everyone goes eventually accepted you
ladies he Gregor there at the end of the
day on his comfy sofa these males are
down for your iron throne kind of kind
of Westeros ale in his hair that could
be the final episode maybe not maybe no
no don't do that George no we don't want
to do that so tell us about working with
your co-stars on the show as well
because you have some great scenes in
Charles dancing dick because one of the
guys you work with isn't it what the
whole series of Game of Thrones fattier
who's who of you know film and
television and theatre you've got
amazing characters like cataractas like
Charles dance you know that scene that I
shared with the Charles dance in time
where Lannister's office you know it's
like being in the Headmaster's office at
school you know sort of being called in
for being it for being a naughty boy you
know Charles dance just has this amazing
authoritarian presence you know it's a
tussle of the guys well of course we
said you played many characters a White
Walkers over on the characters you play
what did it has it compare getting in
that gear to be a white Walker than it
did getting in the gear for predator
predator well very similar sort of
construction to the costumes you know
the other suits are made of latex foam
rubber very tight fitting the the white
Walker gosh steamers was basically like
a leotard you know an elaborate leotard
over tight fitting over light the
predator costume varied in weight from
20 kilos to about 45 the seen die
performers the white Walker required no
actual prosthetic right at the beginning
and they developed how they look haven't
they yes because most of the most it was
shot very very dark maybe dot lighting
and a lot of time in a widescreen what
nothing was stuck on me it was a it was
just a mask every dimension we masks now
because the white Walker is featured in
close up a lot more now it's a it's a
more elaborate prosthetic application it
is one of the iconic monsters of Game of
Thrones
yeah we're not I'm still not entirely
sure what these what these things are
they are the undead are these you know
ghosts are the evil demons or the
wraiths you know or all these things in
there they're trying to invade Westeros
and you've got whole armies of wildlings
trying to trying to escape for the
Malayan waste to to the north of
Westeros it is put in their path so I
think
I think we're gonna learn a lot more
about what these characters actually are
in season three and the first episode we
see you as a Giants don't we what was it
like the whole getup for the Giants
costume and it looks like you're on
stilts is that is that right or was that
CG how did it work no I'm not on stilts
no I was made up as if I was a giant
which was will which is a departure for
me because I've never actually played a
real giant and then we did the real we
did the close-up scenes in Iceland on
location and we did the wide shots
against a green screen to get a proper
size enhancement so how was it bullying
all these things I've heard from other
cast members who we've spoken to like
row sizing who shot out there it's
absolutely beautiful
what was your impression of filming out
there and is it difficult as well as
it's challenging terrain in which to
shoot a TV programme yeah it is
challenging challenging conditions
primarily the weather we were stuck I
flew out and was stuck in this little
town called accuAir II in the north of
the country for about two days with one
of the actor other actors because we
couldn't get to the location which was
on the other side of the mountain range
because we just had about two feet of
snow the night before and the the snow
plowers hadn't cleared the Rose yet so
he was sitting in his hotel twiddling
our thumbs and of course the production
were waiting for the weather to clear
when the weather cleared my god it was
absolutely beautiful you know clear blue
sky and other contrasts of the sky and
the you know the pristine
why'd snow that just ones absolutely
amazing what does it meant to you to be
part of Game of Thrones yeah it's the
HBO's number one TV show and you know
what it's not an honor to be a part of
it it really is and to play multiple
characters as well you know they can
keep offering me parts I don't like and
we look forward to seeing many more and
would you like to send a message to the
fans what would you like to say to the
fans who are watching this video with
you I'd like to say the fans thank you
for watching and for making it what it
is because the production is driven by
the fans and as long as the fans keep
enjoying it then we'll keep making
you